there is a stunning new claim
in an upcoming book that former uh
trump adviser strategist and really
insider steve bannon believed
that donald trump was already suffering
from the early stages of dementia
this is written up quite concisely
in an article in the guardian by martin
pangeli
where the article says former white
house strategist steve bannon
thought that donald trump was suffering
from early stage dementia
and campaigned to covertly remove him
from
office via the 25th amendment according
to ira rosen
a veteran tv producer ira rosen is the
author of a new book
about his work at cbs called ticking
clock behind the scenes
at 60 minutes he spoke to the yahoo news
podcast skullduggery and said to the
host michael issikoff and daniel clayman
that his book was not meant to be about
any particular
person that it was supposed to be a view
about what goes on inside this role of
producer
and when the topic of stephen bannon
came up
ira rosen said steve is a big talker a
big gossiper
and he became a source for many media
people in washington
and goes on to say that
steve bannon quote believed trump was
suffering
from early stage dementia and that there
was a real possibility
he would be removed from office by the
25th amendment
where the cabinet could vote the
president was no longer mentally capable
of carrying out his duties he also wrote
that
one text message from bannon said
you need to do the 25th amendment piece
by the way brother
i never steer you wrong the idea being
to get a piece
aired on cbs uh about the idea this is
quite quite early in the game of using
the 25th amendment to remove
donald trump um this is
so i mean listen there was speculation
about trump's cognitive faculties
uh for for quite some time and to hear
that someone so close to trump at least
for a period of his president's
presidency particularly the earlier part
of his presidency
where the concerns were not as great
about trump's cognitive state
uh it is it is stunning and it is
incredible now
there's a very cynical analysis here the
the simplest analysis the one that
requires the fewest assumptions and
complications
is this is really what steve bannon
believed
and he said it to ira rosen okay that's
that's the simplest
here's a more cynical analysis that a
few people emailed me
imagine that steve bannon wants to
help trump in some way imagine that it
is believed
that at some point donald trump is going
to face maybe multiple
criminal charges uh in the state of
georgia the state of new york we know
about all these different investigations
we learned last week trump is under
criminal probe
in georgia for that supposedly perfect
phone call asking for 11 000 votes
what better way to start mounting
a defense for trump than to start
getting out there
early before there's even any charges
um mitigating factors about donald
trump's state of mind
and intent because there is no doubt and
i did this is
this is a cynical hypothesis i'm not
saying it's mine
it's one that i've been reading that
some believe
if you are going to prove some of what
would be the likely
crimes maybe trump would be accused of
and this is all very speculative
a lot of it will be state of mind and
intent what did trump believe he was
doing
what was trump's understanding of the
things he was saying and doing
if you can start planting seeds of doubt
listen even steve bannon
back in 2018 whenever this supposedly
took place
even then steve bannon was talking about
this guy might have early stage dementia
that would certainly be a juicy ripe
mitigating factor
for a defense attorney that's a cynical
perspective
the idea that trump's best defense if he
is charged would be some kind of
insanity to defense or or unable to even
understand what's going on defense
my view is that steve bannon had an
inside look at what we all had an
outside look of and there were
a look at and there were real questions
about trump's cognitive state
the videos of donald trump saying where
is rudy giuliani when rudy giuliani is
three feet across the table from him
trump coming off of the plane and
wandering off looking for his car when
his car was right there and a secret
service agent taking him by the by the
arm and bringing him back to his car
trump talking about the oranges of the
investigation
oh you know there's dozens of these
examples maybe steve bannon just had an
inside look at more of that exact same
stuff and we have other reports from
inside the white house that sometimes
when trump would say i never said that
it wasn't that trump was lying it's that
trump's memory was gone that's another
claim that was made by people close to
trump
we don't know we don't know um but
uh there are both cynical as well as
just very literal
uh interpretations and understandings of
what it is that we are seeing uh
alleged by steve bannon here maybe we
will learn more about it in the time to
come